bford for the October plans committee
meeting unfortunately due to technical
difficulties technical difficulties we
cannot be on YouTube this morning but
the meeting is still being recorded
internally we are now are
we apologies we are now on YouTube so
welcome to anyone listening on
YouTube there is no planned fire drill
for this morning so should the alarm go
off please leave the building the way
that you came up and do not use the
lift before we start I'd like to ask the
committee members to introduce
themselves by St to their names and the
W they represent and likewise can the
offices introduce themselves so start on
my left uh good morning everybody my
name is Peter hes I represent Apple I
represent appledore Ward morning my name
is Christie I
represent good morning my name is kit
heel and I represent Milton and Tamar
side
Ward good morning
I'm good morning my name is Chris weedy
I represent she and langry
wward good morning my name is Phil
Pennington and I represent monley and
putford my oh there it is now good
morning I'm Jane Whitaker and I
represent northerm and Orchard Hill
thank
you good morning Chris leather I
represent Northern and Orchard
Hill good morning I'm rosby Lo and I
represent two rivers and three Ms so
starting on the end there for the
officers good morning my name is sandre
I'm the committee
CL good morning I'm Stacy Dory and I'm
head of league on
governance good morning I'm Helen Smith
the planning
manager good morning my name is Peter
Stapley I'm Prin uh play off thank you
very much so moving on to the agenda
item number one
apologies no apologies chair thank you
item number two to receive the minutes
of the meeting held the 7th of
September thank
you can I just ask that uh I think we've
agreed s already that I did send
apologies and I was substituted by D
Doug bushby yeah thank you cancer pain
in the minutes have been amended to
reflect and I think the same applies to
council Whitaker as well doesn't that
yeah yes so we have a propose could we
have a
second
yeah thank you chair councelor
Christie councelor hes councelor heppo
four councelor Le four councelor lock
four councelor Pennington
abstain councelor Smith for councelor
weatley for councelor
whiterain thank you very much item
number three Declarations of
interest can I just ask on page nine of
the agenda um I did raise about uh
publicizing the cost decision can I ask
what happened to
that um it it's not been it's not been
determined yet so
we the way it works is the planning
inspectorate directs that the council
sends their their costs or of the appeal
across which has been done um and it's
then awaiting the inspector's decision
indicates it's to be agreed with the
with the appellant so we I don't have a
confirmed well it wasn't the sum of
money involved it was a principle yeah
that we're getting more and more Appeals
um just to show that it isn't just a
free pass abely and this person is going
to have to pay for what was basically a
hopeless appeal yes but we've had
another one I noticed on our agenda
today so I think I would like it
publicized just to let people know
absolutely and I I would certainly agree
with that I think there would be Merit
in doing that on once the the figure is
confirmed and it's it's agreed with the
appellant um then we would certainly
look to to publish that that I think
that's a good
idea right moving on item number three
then Declarations of Interest members
with interest to declare should refer to
the agenda item and describe the nature
of their interest when the item is being
considered elected members of Devon
County Council and town and Parish
councils who have considered a plan and
application by virtue of their
membership of that Council hold a
personal interest and are deemed to have
considered the application separately
and the express views of that council do
not bind the members concerned to
consider the application of fresh which
may include further
information item number four agreements
between Parts one and two we have no
part
two item number five urgent matters I
have none I don't know whether the plan
manager or the solicitor have
any no
okay item number six public
participation the order of speaking is
member of the town of Parish Council two
members of the public against two
members of the public in support and all
of the above have three minutes each and
finally the war member may speak and
they are not limited to three minutes I
will read out the names of those who
have rited to speak when we come to each
application so item number seven going
on to the plan and
applications first application is
1stroke 0308 surf Bay Holiday Park and
it's on pages 11 to 24 of your
agenda are there any Declarations of
Interest no so I now ask the officer to
get the
presentation yeah juel hatted I'm a
member of northern's planning committee
as well thank
you
jel hated as member of both
councils thank you chair um yeah so my
name is Peter Stapley I was the case
officer um for this application which is
223f um as chair said it's demolition of
the existing surf Bay Holiday Park
reception building and proposed mix use
two-story building and holiday unit uh
it was a resubmission of uh application
just to provide a quick verbal update I
believe um because the agenda did not
have a map on the front um that was a
formatting error um a map is included in
this presentation and it was shown
during site visits um so just to make
that clear the application was called in
to be heard at plans committed by
Council Hudson um for the following
reasons the scale of the building
visible from the northern Burrows a trip
SII uh contrary to local plan policy DM
8 um a three- story structure would
dominate the street scene the roof
Terrace a recreational space would be
likely to have detriment to effect on
the privacy and the right for quiet
enjoyment of the nearby residencies and
Gardens next slide please thank you so
here we have um a location plan you can
see there uh the Caravan Park is the
wider site um and the application site
is just highlighted in the middle there
with the existing building next slide
pleas and we just have an aerial uh
image here so we got the highway along
the south bound uh boundary there um and
you can see the Caravans and neighboring
Residential Properties to the South and
you also have some to the West
there just provide a policy context um
so it is outside the development
boundary um but considered to be within
the development Coast um there's the
local plan policies and it's north five
um there for the tourist
area this is the front elevation in
context with the highway you can see uh
at the bottom of the image um the
existing reception building um set back
from the South Boundary of the
site this is the highway access viewing
East and the highway access view to the
West uh because it was called in uh the
impact of the street scene so this just
to show um the current Street Scene
context you can see there
um the tree uh on the South Boundary the
uh building behind that tree and you can
see the manager accommodation just to
the left of that tree there um where the
site entrance
is and again just the street context
from the from the uh West Side so you
see the manag accommodation which is
current uses um tourism accommodation
and the site access there so the site be
just behind that managers accommodation
there uh this is the front front
elevation just a closer view without the
context and this is a view from the
front uh elevation view in South you can
see the Residential Properties on the
other side of the highway
there and here's the rear
elevation and A View From the rear
elevation showing the the Caravan Park
and and beyond that is the trip SII and
the northern
burs this is the side elevation so the
west elevation uh just showing context
there with the manager accommodation on
the right um the highway access for the
park and then the residential dwellings
uh beyond
that and again just another front
elevation in context with that managed
accommodation and here we have landscape
views uh this was from taken from the
northern Burrows uh looking back onto
the site so the site is in the middle of
the uh developed area
there this is the existing site
plan and here's the proposed site plan
for
the
application the existing elevations just
shown there a single story dwell uh
building and here's the proposed
elevations uh existing floor
plan and the proposed flaw plan so two
story with a
terrorists here at the back sorry I'm a
little oh sorry and here's the proposed
Street Scene um showing the context of
the manag accommodation um and then the
neighboring uh Workshop
building the material considerations in
this case are the principle of
development impact on character
appearance the landscape impact impact
on residential amenities access parking
and Highway Safety
fou and surface water drainage impact on
wildlife and ecology and the conclusion
the reasons outlined in my report uh I'm
recommending uh approval uh with the
following
petitions as shown on at the back of my
report okay thank you very much for that
report we now go on to the public
speakers list the first person is Claire
Stacy who's speaking against the
application if you'd like to come down
the front and put your microphone
on you have three minutes when you're
ready good morning uh we own the
property directly opposite the Holiday
Park and will be significantly impacted
by this development we are speaking
against the proposed development on the
following grounds the sheer scale and
mass of the development will have a
hugely detrimental impact on the
surrounding properties and the landscape
and on Gulf Links Road as a whole
creating a corridor
the visual impact is overbearing in
design and appearance and I call into
question the need for another
five-bedroom holiday property as
currently there are 12 five-bedroom
holiday properties in Westwood ho alone
and 33 within a 5 mile radius and that
is with just one Local Company this is a
three-story development regardless of
the wording stating its two-story with a
roof Terrace it's still three stories
high we have significant concerns about
the noise and environmental impact upon
all the neighbors from the roof Terrace
the properties adjacent to this
development are narrow eastborn Terrace
and this designs wide elevation faces
the road the impact on the landscape
will be significant if the design was
rotated perhaps 90 degrees this would
have more of a visually inke keeping
appearance to the adjacent Street and
have less of an impact on Gul Links Road
also after reading the planning officers
report we also call into question the
timings given for any building work to
start from 7:00 a.m. to 7:00 p.m. this
is a residential and holiday area and
would impact upon the general well-being
of all in the vcinity including the
Holiday Park itself whilst we appreciate
building's need renewing the impact of
the scale and design of this development
will affect many and Westwood ho in a
seriously detrimental way so we request
that this current sign is rejected thank
you for your
time our next speaker is Katie
car okay um good morning um I strongly
object to the proposed development as
its overbearing this is a three-story
property recognized as such by the
council's previous refusal the roof
terce can and will serve as a third
floor The Proposal is unlike any other
in the area therefore no comparison can
be made so far as noise light pollution
or the impact on residents and the local
community it will also create a corridor
effect into the village along Golflinks
Road the proposed development will
impact the local area with viewing
balconies and roof Terrace which will be
an invasion of public privacy and have
an overbearing effect on the Northern
Burrows and the public use of footpaths
I would like to challenge the
representation in the committee report
in relation to nearby views the report
states that the views from northern
Burrows are already dominated by the
Caravan Park I would argue that a single
story Caravan would not block out a
three story 1232 M squared 10 birth
property it is also stated in the report
that the building will sit well below
the visible slope behind it I challenge
this as it will dominate all existing
views from opposite residential
Bungalows I would like to ask why
Northern Council now recommend the
application after multiple
refusals the proposed development will
encroach on my own my young families and
surrounding neighbors personal
immunities it will reduce my and my
family's personal enjoyment within our
private dwelling and will be an invasion
of privacy with the displeasure of being
overlooked I have the right to privacy
in my own home and garden and believe in
particular that the balconies which will
be capable of holding 10 people will
look directly into my private garden and
living space and it is in direct
contradiction to the ND TLP stance on
intrusion I would like to ask how you
would feel if this building was at the
end of your
garden thank
you and our final speaker Rebecca
Fernley speaking in
support thank you and um good morning
everyone yes so I'm here to speak in
support of the application so there's
been a lot of reference to the planning
history obviously ly so we had approval
for very similar schemes in 2014 then
was followed up in
2016 by um a sort of renewal of that
application those were both dealt with
by delegated decisions and approvals um
and then it kind of fell off radar over
the sort of pandemic and things and the
client didn't take the application
forward so then in
2022 we brought a new application which
looked at changing the accommodation so
previously we had had approval for two
two-bedroom units but um what became
clear was and what Miss Stacy referred
to there are 12 five bedroom properties
in Westwood ho and this was probably
with the same letting companies I've got
similar statistics but there's also 52
two bedrooms um travel chapter UK have
um provided some supporting evidence on
this and said that in
2023 there were
13,410 searches for properties that
sleep 10 people of which there are only
12 in Westwood ho versus 10,000 for
properties that sleep um four people
which are the two-bedroom properties
obviously and um there are 52 of those
in Westwood hose so it does show that
there is a situation where the demand is
um outstripping what we currently have
supplied so my client who runs surf Bay
wanted to um address that and address
that only Supply within his business
because obviously he has quite a lot of
Caravans but he wanted to look at an
upgrade to the building and also
providing a different type of Acom
accommodation and offering um I
understand then that well there was a
refusal in 2022 because we'd added a
roof Terrace but we'd also added a stair
Tower to sort of access the roof Terrace
and I think the um that was felt to be
unacceptable so we have amended the
design and gone back through and
discussed this with count uh with um
planning officers to come to something
that everyone felt was more acceptable
it is a two-story building and the roof
Terrace is within the roof of what you'd
say is a traditional pitch streef
building so um it is no higher than a
traditional two-story building with a
sort of 40 degree pitch roof um so it's
not out of context in that in in those
terms really um it also does sit amongst
quite a you know a big there's a big
landscape sort of backdrop and also the
you you've got East Bourn Terrace that
sets the kind of scale for the area as
well which is significantly larger than
what we're proposing I want to address
the overlooking as well because I do
understand that there are always
concerns about this but my understanding
is where you've got a large public
Highway between the dwellings and we're
looking at sort of at front Gardens and
front of properties that there can't
really be an overlooking concern I
understand that there's a lot of view
but as we all know view isn't yeah view
isn't um
isn't um controlled by planning the last
thing I want to reflect on quickly is
that Council Hudson called it in in May
for a number of reasons but since then
the amended design has been to Northern
Town Council and Council Hodson actually
seconded the approval um which was in
August 23 so we hope that members can
follow the offic of recommendation for
approval thank you for your
time right we no further public speakers
so I open up the matter for discussion
who'd like to kick
off thank you chair well I was surprised
to see this called in to plans committee
to be honest probably for the reason
that um have just been
mentioned but as to the overlooking
issues this building is set back
actually set back from the road it's a
replacement could you put the picture up
again of it that faces the road the
actual what would face the
road yeah not yeah the elevations yeah
that's the one the cont
one that's the elev yeah the top one is
what would face the road and there is
that balcony there the roof Terrace is
in behind at the
top uh and you can see with the bottom
foot picture that's facing onto the site
to the Caravans so that's the Terrace
that you can see on the top level within
the
roof there's a manager's building next
door which is virtually the same height
that this would be and then of course
eastborn Terrace which is alongside this
site so I honestly do not believe
there's any issue of overlooking from
this site the Bungalows across the road
are set well back from that road from
Gulf Links Road so you know I
uh I don't think there's any problem
overlooking from it and the building
needs upgrading it'll look a lot better
than the flat roof thing that's there
presently so I'm happy to move approval
of this
chair yeah I very much agree with the
previous comments from Council Lether it
is a balance between the immunity of
neighboring properties but in the
context of where it is and eastborn
Terrace which was mentioned uh
previously there a balance between the
two and I I hear both sides but I I I
don't see enough to refuse it at the
present moment so I Echo what our
previous speaker has said I hear what
the immunity is but I think on balance
unless I hear differently I'll come to
the decision I will approve and I will
say
councelor leather's
proposal
yes um yeah perhaps I should have asked
this at the site visit but um I see
nothing about flooding in the officer's
report and there's nothing from the
environment agency I seem to recall when
the building next to the site that the
larger building
was um approved there was an escape room
inside the building um reflecting the
situation of possible flooding so um can
I ask through you chair what situation
is
there so I think um with the manager
comination can I ask what um is it on
flood one or two I can't remember what
the designation
is
while the officer is um checking that
piece of information I've just got one
query um condition six I was pleased to
see about the operational hours but I
can remember in another application with
the roof Terrace that we also condition
that no furniture be allowed on the
balcony is that something we could do is
that this
application
um I I believe we have used a condition
to that effect where there may have been
a sort of Heritage link like in the
conservation area or where you wouldn't
want a roof Terrace to be filled with
paraphernalia that could harm the visual
amenity of the area um is this the front
roof Terrace that the the roof Terrace
or the um it it would be open to you to
suggest that but we would need to
understand why there's no amenity
concerns raised around the sighting of
that roof Terrace it is at the rear of
the building um there isn't that that
same visual amenity as I understand it
from from the roof Terrace it's not as
if it's sort of prominent in the street
scene um so we would really need to
understand why you want to not have
furniture on there there there's not a
cited amenity concern um and obviously
the roof Terrace is quite a key part of
the overall building so um but it's open
to members to to consider that thank
you flood zone one so that's over the
next 100 years or
what
thank you um yeah I think the roof
Terrace and the furniture you referring
to was Alan Smith's
application uh which was fairly
contentious um what I wanted to raise I
I couldn't quite understand when I
looked at this uh it highlighted by
Council leather why councilor Hodson had
called it in and then voted for it at
the Northern Town Council I mean she
could have with withdrawn the call in I
don't know why she didn't I mean there
was as you say councel Le there was
quite a time between them why she didn't
call in I don't know but I was intrigued
because I went back to the original
application that Mrs Fern that was
considered to be unacceptable um as that
would create an overbearing and
dominance um of the design and
especially along that Highway of goink
Road um given the height and the scale
on the end location uh and elevation
coming along ginks road that would be uh
one of the main
that you would see and that create
overbearing dominance feature there um
discussions were had with the architect
at the time um but they um it wasn't
removed so it was refused on that
basis thank you for that except the
tower isn't referred to in our last
decision at all it actually refers to
the whole development as being uh you
know out of scale density massing height
layout appearance I mean isn't just one
bit it's the whole thing and I still
can't get my head around why it was
turned down a year ago and it's come
back with very little change and now
you're saying go ahead with it it does
seem slightly odd I think we've got to
remember that every application on its
own merits I think that's the important
thing to
remember thank you chairman um change is
always very difficult to accept isn't it
um so I've got a huge amount of sympathy
for the neighbors but I actually think
and on reflection that an actual fact
eventually things won't be half as bad
as they imagined it will be and I don't
think the distance between the building
and and their homes is something that we
can take account of unfortunately so I
shall be voting
support
yeah hours of work um 7:00 start I mean
if it is approved I would suggest that
that was moved to a later time I think
it's it's not acceptable to start work
so early as that this this came up
yesterday on another matter another
planning application we talked
about I think it's too early really so
what alternative would you suggest well
it's normally 7:30 isn't it but I'd say
8 really especially in the
winter so in in this case the
Environmental Protection Officer who
considers amenity from construction
processes recommended those times it
does vary sight to sight Council homes
whether it's 7: am. 7:30 but as a rule a
7 AM start is considered acceptable and
and quite common on construction sites
now um it is of course open to members
to to change that time if you feel that
in this particular case it would warrant
it um but I would emphasize that that
the the professional um statut consult
has indicated 7 a.m. would be acceptable
yeah this is a density populated area
isn't it so it would impinge on
neighbors quite strongly
really all right there's no further
comments yes C whiter thank you chairman
I'd like to come back on that actually
um I agree with um my ccer friend but in
actual fact if you change the conditions
to make it more acceptable and more
meable to local neighbors I suspect
strongly that you will find that they
will not
work right so no further comments it has
been proposed by councilor leather
second by councelor peninon that the
application is approved do you want to
take up Council hs's point and change in
the construction
house no c
p so it is how it stands then so as been
proposed by Council and deed by Council
pendon that the application is
approved thank you chair councelor
Christie councelor
hes councelor heppo for councelor
leather for councelor lock four
councelor Pennington four councelor
Smith four councelor weat Le four
councelor Whitaker
four that's seven for and two against
chair approval thank you very much so
moving on to application number two on
the agenda one Str
0791 Y Bar holid elect and it is on
pages 25 to 34 of your
agenda I just wait for members of the
public to
leave
are there any Declarations of
Interest no I now ask the officer to
give the presentation then thank you
Helen so the the case officer is
actually on leave so um I'm going to to
present the planning application there
is a connected listed building
application which is item c um the
listed boarding application relates to
exactly the same proposal as the
planning application um the conservation
officer Sarah Chapel dealt with the
listed building application so what
we're going to do is run through a
single presentation will be a combined
effort on that but for for members to be
mindful that it is exactly the same
proposal the listed building application
relates to exactly the same detail
however separate consideration will be
needed needed to be given to both
applications so I will run through the
material planning considerations for the
planning application um ster will then
run through the listed
building application consideration so I
hope that's clear but just to say that
both both applications are relevant to
to the presentation you're about to see
um also just to clarify that this
application is before you for
consideration due to the applicant being
related to a staff member so it's not
actually been called in by a ward member
or a member of plans
committee so this this is shows um sort
of an an aerial shot and the submitted
location plan as you can see the site is
lo located within a rural location it's
it's within the yo Valley um it is it's
accessed via um a rural Lane so direct
access where you can see the red line
joining the highway um is is onto a very
sort of narrow rural Lane that's rural
Lane loops around and there are actually
two points of connection to the C4 61
Road below which is the main road that
that heads s towards Brad withy um the
site is in an elevated position as you
all have seen from some of the photos
that was shared on the site visit um it
does sit up above the valley with the
highway set below um it is actually well
screened as well as also you would have
seen um there is some significant mature
trees around and also um well
established hedge rows down below um
members who were on the the planning
committee um during the last Council
will probably recall doing an in-person
site visit here to look at a conversion
of another building to a dwelling um
it's um which is up in the main the main
cluster of the buildings so I'll just
move on to the block plan now and I'll
actually hand across to Sarah who who
will just talk talk through the scheme
the drawings and some
photos hello the um this is quite an
unusual scheme not in in that the
building actually still survives and
still the form of this um settlement
still retains um these traditional
buildings uh yoil house is a gentleman's
residence set on the side of the valley
and as a gentleman's residence it would
have required certain buildings to
support it including a carriage house uh
green houses the carriage house has been
converted you uh heard my colleague say
that that that was a site visit in
person this proposal is to convert some
ancillary buildings which are attached
to the bottom of a very nice Walled
Garden which would have been necessary
for the gentleman to feed himself um you
can see that it's an l-shape of
buildings it's described as a Lin which
is the um east west building and it has
a lean two section which comes back uh
which has a a sort of very attractive
corrugated roof at the moment the access
is really on foot can't get from from
the plan obviously is the Topography of
the site which is why it was quite
important that you looked at the
photographs on the virtual site
visit the buildings are cited at the
bottom of the ward garden they're
nestled right into the valley and the
trackway to the right hand side is
actually the traditional way of
accessing with the should we say the
tradesman's entrances so the proposal
now is to convert what remains of the
Lin and the leant to to a holiday leting
unit which will retain the buildings
part of the wider complex and W Garden
if I can have
another slide so this is the um the
plans so the existing plans you can see
it's got a nice pantile roof which uh is
typical of an out building and dates the
building quite nicely because pantiles
are no longer made um that will be
retained and you can see that it's
actually walled in on the other side by
the Garden Wall and there's an archway
through from the trackway so this part
of the site is completely contained as
it would have been as part of the the
functional part of the estate I have
another slide please so here are the um
proposed plans you can see the panar
roof remains uh the open part of the Lin
is glazed uh and you would only get
glimpses of that through from inside the
W Garden itself um and the track way to
the side you can see there's a tiny
glimpse of the the glazing it's all
enclosed uh the lean to section of the
roof is going to be replaced with a
similar or modern metal
roof if I can have another slide I think
we've got some photograph so the access
is across the front of the house and the
the visitors will leave their car there
and then they will go on foot down
through the wall garden and you can see
the wall Garden quite nicely there and
you can only just about see the roof of
the building hidden behind the
vegetation like to carry and then you
can see the archway from the track and
the internal view of the ward Garden
currently laid to Grass um and this is
the internal Courtyard where all the the
changes will happen you can see the rly
tin roof which will become a metal roof
and see the internal
structure and I think we're sort of
there with unless
anyone's got
[Music]
any them to any questions I have to say
um
presentation um so I'll just run through
the material considerations for the
planning application this is item 7B so
in terms of the principle of development
as set out in the officer's report The
Proposal does involve reuse and
conversion of an existing building um
therefore policies dm18 and dm27 are
relevant and it is considered to comply
with both of those um there is the
condition recommended to restrict the
use to Holiday H holiday use only um in
terms of visual impact and Landscape
character um the site is is very
visually contained um due to the
landscape mature trees and also the the
W Garden itself does does actually
screen the the the the building as it is
um attached to it on one end it is
recommended that conditions be included
to remove committed development rights
and also that that material samples are
are received and um approved prior to
construction um Heritage assets there is
an accompanying listed building
application the conservation officer has
looked at this proposal in detail and
provided comments raising no objection
it is considered to be acceptable under
mppf paragraphs 197 to 202 and also the
the listed buing Conservation Area
planning act um
no significant harm is noted and also is
considered to be an Optimum use of of a
building that is currently disused there
are no amenity concerns the building is
set some um some distance from any other
um unconnected
property drainage is acceptable High
highways and parking members may recall
from the previous application those that
that were involved in the consideration
of that the the access onto the sea Road
um
at at the time of considering the
previous application a condition was
included to secure Highway improvements
and visibility improvements which have
been undertaken and that condition has
been fully discharged those Highway
improve improvements which were shown um
photos of which was shown at the site
visit do um provide adequate visibility
to oncoming traffic on that side of the
road however due to land ownership
issues no Highway improvements can or
have been made in the other direction
which would be on the the sort of not
the immediate Carriage Way um so that
there is there is a a a slight conflict
in terms of Highway policies however
with the previous application it was
considered that the the improvements
that were secured were a betterment and
any and it also has to be weighed
against the the benefit of securing that
listed building's Optimum use and then
finally ecology
the application is accompanied by um a
bat survey that a license is required
and a condition is included to ensure
that that that happens that is a
separate process in any event and also a
need for mitigation for swallows was
identified as well and there is a
condition recommending that so subject
to those mitigation measures there's no
objection in terms of ecology um so so
given all of that the recommendation is
one of
approval it's go
well I went to the original site visit
to this place it's real hot oh sorry I
didn't realize that
sorry I speaker Mr Chris EV speaking in
support hi there I was the agent on the
application U my name is Chris Evans and
I director of Coast architects
um that was a really comprehensive
presentation so I don't need to dwell on
any other the points you've already
raised uh but I guess it's good to cover
why this project came about in the first
place and the barn is capable of
conversion as illustrated by the
structural report um but it is showing
signs of Decay and it needs work and at
the moment it is just a tool store at
the bottom of w Garden a very beautiful
W Garden so to justify the expense on
repairing the building and making it
safe and secure for another 50 to 100
years uh we recommended the change of
use and I think responding to dm18 and
uh the expansion of the tourism use
that's already on site I think it is a
really unique offering to the area and
will greatly improve uh their their
business as well with that with that
with that set up by the the two sides of
the uh of the barn um and again looking
at the legibility of the history and The
Narrative of the site the intervention
has been purposely quite modern as well
so a lot of glass and then using
uh using using Timber and concrete and
metal Still Still materials that are
common in agricultural aesthetic but
using those to contrast against that you
know the historic rough face Stone and
cob um that's all I've I've really got
to add it was yeah very good
presentation by uh by Sarah and Helen
so thank
you thank you um yeah I did go to the
site visit uh last last time and it was
a real hotch poch of buildings there and
I was very envious of their W Garden I
have to say um but the thing that did
let it down was this building these
buildings they're talking about actually
which weren't you know they were out of
keeping with the rest of it um so I've
got no problem with propos I propose
that we accept this uh if it sits well
with the conservation officer then that
is an added bonus for
me I'd like to second that proposal an
actual fact I I had one concern and that
was the highways issues because I I
actually know that road relations of
mine used to go and stay there many
years ago and that road can take some
fairly fast traffic on occasions it's a
shame that nothing can be done but all
in all I think I would be quite happy to
Second The Proposal thank
you
it's yeah
um yes I can't see anything wrong with
the actual approach to the uh
development I'm there is have a concern
about the effect on bats I noticed that
the Lesser horseshoe is one of the bats
which roosts there um of course they're
very pretty scarce in this country um I
I just ask you chair what's the
situation about can't go ahead is that
the case and do they in your experience
recommend or look to an alternative
roosting site what's the process please
and usually planning permission is is
needed before that license can be
applied for the ecology report is quite
clear that those discussions have
already taken taken place it's a very
detailed ecology report that highlights
the need um it can be a range of
mitigation measures that can be pursued
it depends on whether a different of bat
house or habitat is required um or if it
is just mitigation whilst works are
taking place and that would all be dealt
with through the license and if the
license isn't isn't given then no they
would they would be um it would
essentially be a criminal offense to to
carry out the works without that so that
is needed orbe it it is important to
know is a separate process um to
planning but one that would impact on
those on those
works thank you for that sorry can I
just ask yes come yeah does notice that
I can't see the conservation officers
report in the documents um can I ask
that
then this has happened when we look at
planning applications at Northern that
we haven't had a report is there any
reason why they don't it doesn't go into
the documents the conservation officer
response is on page
27 no I meant in the
document
up upload right there been an emission
to be uploaded it should be upload yeah
it it should normally that should be on
on the system for people to view I
apologize it's probably because I didn't
upload right have we got any the C yes
Council Smith uh thank you chair um just
a couple of points of information if I
may you're talking about the roof
material being a metal I mean a lot of
the other roofs there are pan tiled and
I know they're unavailable they must be
available somewhere but but what sort of
material I'm sure it's very much in
keeping but it's just a point of
information if I could um and the other
the other thing um is uh uh we're
specifying holiday use only could you
specify exactly what that
entails thank you so so condition just
check so condition five um on on of the
report of of the the recommendation says
Ed for Holiday accommodation and no
other purpose um it it is a sort of
matter of fact and degree at what point
point something is H you know holiday
accommodation or not we don't tend to
put a sort of specified time scale we
could ex sometimes we there are
conditions we use which expand slightly
specifying not as a second home we could
add something additional additional to
that effect but essentially it shouldn't
be a
permanent Appo a permanent residence
essentially would would be that that
that's that test is that the kind of uh
application sometimes you have to keep
the place vacant for one
month in the year or it's that kind of
thing we're talk historically we used to
put condition historically there were
conditions that would require maybe only
nine or 11 months of the year to be
occupied we we we don't tend to do that
now um I you know that that gives us
enough mechanism to to enforce that but
it but the distinction is it not being a
permanent permanent resident thank you
thank
you all right any other further comments
if the other question ch sorry it was
about the the roof material sorry thank
you I'm wondering might be worth going
back to the um elevation plan we whoa
there um you can just see it's proposed
to be um like a a rolled
steel sheet roof that's coming down so
it it will just you can't use wrigly tin
your other option would have been
plastic coated box profile so I think
this this will weather in much more
appropriately um and it actually faces a
hedge line so it's going to be very
unusual someone gets that view yeah um
the the view really is from the other
side of the
valley which is quite where that was in
um I bought these because because I've
got them um this was in
2000 and um Council hes will be pleased
to see that
it's um rather different now with the
Landscape
Management so that the buildings
virtually invisible in the landscape
Lely thank you thank you very much thank
you chair if I could just add to that
chair there is a condition requiring a
sample of that roofing material as well
prior prior to it being constructed so
you know there is an opportunity then
for the conservation officer to have a
look and and and for us to be sure that
it's
appropriate just briefly I do know South
your house I used to know the person who
owned it good few years ago it's a
lovely house I should think the loft
there the roof space is full full of
bats I should think down there so I
won't worry about the bats on on this
one right so at the moment then we're
dealing with
0791 um so it's been proposed by
councelor Christie seconded by councelor
Whitaker that the application is
approved thank you chair councelor
Christie councelor hes councelor he four
councelor leather four councelor lock
four councelor
Pennington four councelor Smith four
councelor weatley four councelor whiter
four unanimous to approve chair thank
you and then we move on to the list of
building consent
0792 so we would need a propos and
second for this
one Sarah CH can just quickly run the
considerations are just slightly
different if she could do that
and just quickly obviously we've
considered this as a curage structure so
it is um subsidiary to the main house
which is the listed structure and this
is listed by virtue of being part of the
um paraphernalia of the um holding in
this case we again we have to consider
whether it harms the significance of the
building and in this case I came to the
conclusion that The Proposal does not
harm the significance nor the setting of
The Host dwelling and therefore we
consider that it's acceptable under
paragraph 16 of uh of the planning list
of buildings and conservation areas Act
and the guidance set out in paragraph
202 of the
nppf anyone got any comments to make on
this application
then so it has been yes I I would just
like to say it seems to be very much in
keeping with uh with what we would
expect and I would I would propose that
we accept this it's already been
proposed by councelor Chris secreted by
councelor heo yeah so could we go to the
vote
please yes chair councelor
Christie councelor hes four councelor
heppo four councelor leather councelor
lock councelor Pennington four councelor
Smith four councelor weatley four and
councelor Whitaker four unanimous chair
thank you very
much moving on to application number one
stroke
0507 the demolition of the storage
shared in the direction of one dwelling
at the molesworth arms pyworthy and is
on pages 40 to 49 of your agender are
there any Declarations of Interest
please yes coun so have to declare an
interest because it is me and my wife
who are the applicants
so I will leave the room thank you very
much thank you
chair uh Planning Commission is proposed
for the demolition of an existing
storage shed in the direction of one
dwelling at molesworth Arms that's at
pyworthy hold um a couple of Miles um
west of
holsworth this is satellite image U you
can see molesworth arms identified on
this uh Google Map it's centrally
located within the uh
settlement this is the location plan you
see the red line plan that surrounds the
uh the existing storage
building this is the existing building
it's um regarded as a non-designated
Heritage asset it's uh a rendered cob uh
storage building associated with
historically with molesworth
arms it's uh has a natural slate roof um
and cart doors which front on uh to the
public
Highway this is the proposed block
plan these are the pro proposed
elevations very similar to the existing
building um The Proposal is actually to
demolish the existing building which is
in a poor state of repair we'll see some
photos later that show there have been
previously catastrophic cob collapse so
a very similar building existing
building is actually in two sections
with with a lower rear section The
Proposal is to in effect demolish this
rear section and create um an offset
single story rear extension the main
building would be two stories it would
have a mezanine first floor which would
be um the bedroom so it's a one bedroom
dwelling downstairs is open plan living
area um with kitchen dining area and
there would be an imunity area which
would be on the western side that would
be about 3x3 MERS that would be the area
which is currently the smaller single
story section at the rear of the
property
um to enable natural light there would
be through uh three roof lights um and
there would be a LED um opening above
the cart doors which would uh be
retained and that would be um for a
bathroom this is a
cross-section there were a few concerns
about potential impact uh especially on
the rear neighbor which is um thater
Cottage at the moment there's an
existing um boundary wall uh vegetation
screening the two elements the two
properties but there is at first floor
um a habitable bedroom window which does
face onto the site and this
cross-section just demonstrates that the
single story element uh would have no um
adverse impact on this
window so on to the
photos molesworth arms the the uh the
storage shed is the building in white
the rendered painted white with the cart
doors to the rear you can see the
neighboring
property this is the southern elevation
this is where there was the the cob
collapse um buildings held up with cow
props and this this section was
weatherboarded this is the nearest
residential property suches
Cottage
this is looking back from uh the access
into th's Cottage back um to uh the
central area in in the village into the
front of molesworth
arms this photo is looking southwards
from the parking area in front of
molesworth Arms This is the boundary to
uh St sn's Church which is grade two
star uh listed
[Music]
Church these are images from within what
historically was the the pub Garden it's
not actually used as a pub Garden
anymore it's used as sort of imunity
area for the letting rooms which the
molesworth arms let as holiday
accommodation photos within the building
see the acro props holding the building
up there's um um sort of wooden
structure that's partly holding up the
ceiling as
well this is a photo
of the structure I believe uh the
applicant councelor heel bought the
property in 2015 and this was when it
was in a poor um state of repair and
this is an image of so the tractor
didn't cause this the tractor is is
removing it's removing the cob just in
case you
wondering so the main material
considerations are the principle of
development
um in terms of the principle it's a
schedule B settlement so policy
st7 um it's acceptable it's acceptable
um area um to have a a new
dwelling in terms of impact on Heritage
assets there are there are two parts to
this the first one in terms of the the
storage building because we regard it to
be a non designated Heritage
asset we would in the first instance has
normally looked to retain the building
so if we we can convert it but as you as
you've seen there are significant issues
with the building and in this in this
case it it would be unreasonable to
suggest that they try and retain it or
or rebuild
it um so in that regard we consider the
replacement of the building to be
acceptable and I suppose the secondary
factor is its appearance because the
applicant had actually done
pre-application consultation directly
with historic
previously with a different scheme which
um I think was perhaps very contemporary
and a much larger building the the
comments from historic England were you
really got to reflect what what's
currently there and and one of the
reasons for that is the association with
the public house the surrounding
buildings but also because of the church
there's although the church as you can
see from the the the photo is well
screened it's not what all of the year
and but this site does form part of the
setting of the church so we consider uh
the replacement of the current building
and the proposed uh design is is
appropriate and and
acceptable um in this case in terms of
residential amenity as you saw in the
photos close
relationship with the rear
neighbor I think the cross-section
identifies that actually there wouldn't
be an adverse impact on on the living
conditions of this property there were
concerns raised by uh the Environmental
Protection Team and because the moles
where the arms has a license which
allows it to be until 1:00 so there's
potential impact there on future
residents uh so there is a condition uh
recommended uh accepted by the applicant
which would uh ensure
that uh the consumption of food drink
and uh and music would be limited till
well would would would not be permitted
between the hours of 11: at night and 7
in the
morning um in terms of Highways and
parking the the there is parking area
that's proposed to the south of the
storage shed it it doesn't quite provide
two par two full parking spaces it's
about it's about 1 and a half meters shy
of that in terms of uh the highway
Authority his comments uh they they
issued their standing advice and
typically um we would we would like to
see two parking spaces in this location
um but it falls just short of that
however there is an existing parking
area as you can see from the photos um
to the east of the site so in this case
we wouldn't we wouldn't we don't
consider that to be an overriding Factor
um in this
application thank you chair very much
right there's no rent speakers so we go
straight to the discussion who'd like to
kick
off don't always speak at once yes C
Le yeah I just was thinking that's an
unusual condition on the condition five
that the public house including it
external area for the sale and
consumption of food and drink regulated
entertainment shall cease between the
hours of 2300 and 7 in the morning only
the other way around that that seems to
me to be a very strange planning
condition um the dwelling that's
immediately behind this proposed uh
rebuilding of this
shed they're already there with the pub
in operation as
is I can't think why there's a need to
put that condition in really just
surprised me that it doesn't seem like a
planning condition condition
that I I'm happy to move the application
I'm happy to approve it chair but I just
think that's a very strange condition
that
is there's other properties close by as
well you know it's never been an issue
till that till this I think that's
because the issue has arisen now because
I I don't know the history about
Factory's Cottage but I believe I've
seen some history that it was originally
um converted possibly in the last 20
years but certainly now the today when
our envir Environmental Protection Team
are looking at new residential
development they look at the existing
Baseline impact on them they can't
control what's gone on before um but
they identified we we have um we have a
license there which is not potentially
could impact on these neighbors because
uh the new property because the separ
separation distance is not very great at
all so I mean I have seen it used quite
a lot um and also as the applicant has
pointed out they don't actually open
past 10
anyway uh they you know pubs aren't used
in the same way as they have perhaps
done historically so perhaps the the
issue isn't as great as it was but there
is potential because we don't know in
the future if someone else is going to
take it on and actually they're very
much into you know music and being open
late into the evening uh so this is just
a control and it's I should say the
applicant has agreed to it and they
consider but the condition applies to
the pub itself not to the redline
application site yeah that's right you I
mean you're imposing or trying to impose
a condition on the pub yeah I mean that
is a reasonable thing to do because it's
under the same ownership be because um
we could have said the appli actually
maybe we you we could redraw the red
line but we know they own it so we know
they have control over it and it is very
common for repal appeal inspectors to
say you know we know we we know it's
under their ownership we know they have
control so therefore it meets the tests
for planning condition so I'm quite
comfortable that it's a it meets those
tests can I just come back on that
because um I'm sure you said that the
pub can stay open to 1:00 a.m. at the
current time is that what you
said get yeah so in fact they're losing
two hours trading then
yeah they don't currently use it past
10:00 anyway so so in effect they might
gain an hour but yeah it's not it's not
used in that
way
right
just yes maybe a small point I raised at
the site meeting um throughout the
report it's referred to as moles worthy
I hope that doesn't make any planning
commission
invalid um perhaps we should get the
name right when we issue the planning if
we approve this planning application it
as I understand it it's molesworth and
not
molesworth site address is Mo molesworth
arm
shed I
yeah we we can ensure councilor hes that
obviously the description of development
is key there and if it is referenced in
a condition then we'll take that as that
that can be amended post committee
should committee
approve round a b then yeah I was just
going to say just following on for What
U agree with Council and leather I don't
think there should be any
condition
imposed so are you
yes
so do you want to take that condition
off I think we should remove condition
five it just you know I don't like
things for the sake of putting things in
bureaucracy all the time I don't like it
there's no need for it and I really
don't think we've the right to impose
that so can we do
that it's it's open to the committee to
do
that and he stated clear reasons as as
to why so are you Happ yes counc
Christen I used to sit on the licensing
committee and I thought it'd be
something for the licensing committee
not for
planning because I mean obviously this
is going to be an open market now so it
doesn't you know it won't be in the same
ownership what so the licensing team do
form part of Environmental Protection
Team and it it was that the officer that
deals with licensing and the the
planning Lia an officer that both came
back to me and said we've identified
that we've got reasons for concern here
because the license does allow it open
till 1 and we wouldn't permit we would
not um support a new dwelling that close
to the building where potentially you
could have very loud music and people
drinking and eating till 1:00 in the
morning so that's where the concern
comes from and it is a legit legitimate
one to them yes it might be a but to was
it's just strange and I think it's a lot
better with it Tak
out if the P doesn't Operate Now
normally past about 10:00 fine but if on
occasion there's a wedding party wanted
in the village there and they wanted to
be there till 12: with food and drink
possibly music why shouldn't they have
as you say chair why restrict the the
potential of trading hours there's no
need
to thank you chairman I I think it
should go back to licensing anyway and
in the likely event that that that the
the mwth arms is sold at some stage
right then things could change
dramatically couldn't they I mean they
could have you know all sorts of late
night entertainment in the middle of the
countryside it has been known in the
past what are you saying not saying
anything I'm just
recalling a memory I didn't invite you a
shame get it back to
business thank you chairman so where are
we going with this condition then your
proposal is approval with to remove
condition
five and you happy with that con
we right so it has been proposed by
Council Leather seconded by Council
Whitley that the application is approved
subject to condition five being
withdrawn yeah I mean as I said it's
open to the committee to do that as the
case officer said it is it was a request
from the Environmental Protection Team
so I just want to to emphasize that
you're aware of
that thank you chck councelor Christie
councelor hes councelor hepo oh
sorry
against councelor leather four councelor
Lo four councelor Pennington four
councelor Smith four councelor weat Lee
for councelor Whitaker for unanimous
chair very so someone can ask coun to
return what an
idiot G has gone
together
sorry is that
what
you be pleased to hear counc
he we had an indepth
discussion yes guys W go chairman I
wonder if I could just say something a
minute because I was a little tur about
development was I not conditioned rather
this earlier um and and I really want to
talk about conditions at some stage
with planning members planning
colleagues and I wonder when it could be
done we have a major problem down in Li
Lane with ambery and the reason that I
was very T I know about changing the
hours from early in the morning 7 to 8
is because it's not working down in
Limer Lane at all now I don't know how
how what we do about this I don't know
but I sometimes feel that some
conditions not all but some conditions
just don't ever seem to be resolved
perhaps we could arrange some sort of
meeting particularly to discuss
conditions you know separate committee
very appreciative yeah thank you we we
could certainly do that and whether we
we tag it on to a virtual site visits if
if we have a not not not many on a
particular agenda um we are finalizing
sort of a program of of training to
interact with you as plans committee so
we can certainly incorporate on that as
well so we'll look at when would be best
to do that I I think just to say on
conditions they do they do play a really
important part in decision making um
through mitigation through ensuring
quality of development and you know
particularly construction hour um
conditions are really important they are
routinely recommended by the
Environmental Protection Team um we can
only put conditions on if they meet the
tests and one of those is that it must
be enforcable now with with construction
activities sometimes there's differing
times sometimes it's construction hours
distinct from delivery hours um the the
particular case that that you referred
to councelor Whitaker has you know we
are currently in negotiation with with
the developer um and that's always the
starting point where there is a breach
of of any condition or any breach of
planning um it's not a a quick process
but the the quickest route to a
resolution is usually through
negotiation
um we are separately doing an updating
um enforcement training for members and
for Parish councils so that will be
rolled out as well and I believe our
Democratic Services team we going to
make a previous enforcement presentation
available on on um the the internet for
you but we will be delivering an updated
one um just just so that you can
understand that process and and what we
do at our end but we can bring
conditions into that as well
right going back to your agenda item
number eight yes coun
penon we voted on removing condition
five but we never actually voted
positively to approve the
application have we missed something we
did we did we have done that that's fine
that's good
yeah item number eight the appeal
decisions Pages 50 to 60 one any
comments item number nine cost on
appeals Pages 62 to
64 I thought the potage one
was quite hard to follow
because I think the council put in an
application for cost and because he he
didn't deem it necessary that we went
outside yeah yeah it
it's you usual for cost to be awarded on
on either side um I think on that
particular case as is set out in in the
decision um the council felt it was
reasonable to put a cost application in
however the inspector didn't consider
there had been unreasonable behavior by
the applicant hence it was
refused item number 10 dedicated agmb
applications are
n and item number 11 the planning
decisions started on page
70 71